we are preparing for a very special day  here at eight news now on thursday  and you're invited and the best part is  you'll help others along the way  here's how on thursday june 17th you can  drop off and donate canned and  non-perishable food  bottled water and clothes right here at  our tv station from 6am to 7pm  the address 3228 channel 8 drive we'll  have a drive up drop-off location setup  and your donations will be collected by  8 news now anchors and staff  in a socially distanced manner they will  benefit three square in the salvation  army who will distribute donations  throughout the community  this day will mark the 25th anniversary  of nexstar media group's  founders day a day set aside each year  for local news stations to focus on  giving back to  our community for more details head to  eight news now dot com